Hi Guys.
It's been awhile.
I've been swamped with work as well as
putting together one of my largest
videos ever.
Sorry.
I hope you all bear with me while I get
that finished.
In the gap of uploads though,
I really wanted to tell you about some
awesome things that I thought couldn't
wait.
The biggest thing is that we hit 100,000
subscribers late February,
which is absolutely amazing.
The same time last February,
I had set some goals for this channel
and of all of them,
the most ambitious of them was to get to
50,000
subs in one year.
To really understand how crazy that goal
was to me at the time.
First you have to know that I had a
youtube channel before this making piano
videos and it took me 80 videos over two
years to get 100 subscribers,
so zero to 50 K in one year was pretty
much shooting for the moon and even by
last July I only had 300 subscribers on
this channel.
So I had thought that goal was dead in
the water,
but thanks to you all who watch these
videos and shared them,
we not only hit that goal,
we doubled it.
You all made that amazing goal possible.
So thank you.
Now I think the question is now that we
have all these people here,
what are we going to do to make this
channel even better?
Well first we got our subreddit r slash
coffee break.
One word started on reddit.
We don't have many people there yet,
but that's about to change and it's
going to eventually become a big part of
this community.
We already have a discord,
which is more like a chat room,
but reddit superior comment sorting
makes it better for group discussion.
So why don't you guys to go subscribe
over there.
It's going to be a great place to meet
like minded people and discuss videos
and ideas.
It will also be a place for future
announcements such as the one in this
video.
Secondly,
I wanted to tell you that I do a lot of
research for these videos and I want to
make that more visible going forward.
So I'm going to be putting more and more
effort into getting good footnotes for
these videos.
If you want to learn more about the
subjects I talk about.
The third thing I can't talk too much
about yet,
but I plan on focusing more on coffee
break soon.
If you look at my backlog,
I used to upload once a week,
but that had slowed down because of work
related stuff that's going to change
come April or May and we're going to try
to ramp back up to a more frequent
uploads schedule.
And finally,
as part of the 100 k celebration,
I decided to take this moment to
highlight the lesser known people behind
the show,
the musicians whose music I feature on
the channel.
Music has always been huge for this
channel and I'm sure it's part of the
reason a lot of you like listening to
me.
So I'm going to be uploading a best of
coffee break music mix right after this
video to essentially throw a spotlight
on just how talented these people are.
I'm uploading it separately from this
video,
so if you guys want to just put it on
his study music or whatever,
you don't have to listen to my annoying
preamble every time,
but if I could just ask of you,
when you go to listen to the music mix,
if you like one of the songs,
please go check out the artist's actual
page and comment telling them you came
from coffee break.
All the artists they feature on here are
incredible,
and the songs I show only scratched the
surface.
All right?
That's pretty much it.
To recap,
reddit more videos around April and May
and go check out some of those amazing
artists.
I feel so blessed to reach a hundred k
subs in one year,
and I'm looking forward to where we go
from here.
Thank you for watching.